neue krone regeln neue verunsicherung
die geschäfte bangen um ihren
weihnachtsumsatz künstler und
veranstalter um ihre existenz unterricht
trotz pandemie an den schulen droht das
große durcheinander
die vorgaben sind komplex und oft nur
empfehlungen fassungslosigkeit in
argentinien trauer rund um die welt die
fußballfans nehmen abschied von diego
armando maradona
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend in allen
an diesem donnerstag zum
nachrichtenüberblick heute um 7 kristin
otto hat nachher alles wichtige vom
sport zu es guten abend es ist der tag
an dem die korona beschlüsse von bund
und ländern jetzt umgesetzt werden
müssen
und da sehen wir keine einheitliche
strategie manche bundesländer verhängen
noch strengere beschränkungen
manche sehen die gestern verabredeten
regeln und grenzwerte er als
anhaltspunkt wir berichten ausführlich
in dieser sendung und beginnen mit
thomas konsum und einer übersicht was
denn da gelten soll im dezember in
deutschland privat treffen dürfen sich
ab dem ersten dezember maximal fünf
personen aus dem eigenen und einem
weiteren haushalt ausgenommen sind
kinder bis 14 jahre ab weihnachten wird
gelockert zehn personen können es sein
im engsten familien- oder freundeskreis
kinder zählen auch hier nicht mit all
das soll bis zum ersten januar gelten
beschlusslage gestern und silvester ist
feuerwerk verboten auf belebten plätzen
und straßen restaurants kultur und
freizeitstätten bleiben geschlossen bis
mindestens zum zwanzigster dezember
finanzhilfen gibt es weiter weiter offen
dagegen schulen und kitas in regionen
mit vielen infektionen kann masken
pflicht im unterricht gelten ab klasse 7
masken auf für alle heißt es nun auf
parkplätzen und vor supermärkten
schlange stehen wohl auch denn in großen
geschäften ist vorgeschrieben nicht mehr
als ein kunde auf 20 quadratmetern im
bundestag kanzlerin angela merkel heute
an das gemeinschaftsgefühl aller
deutschen appelliert miteinander und
füreinander einzustehen schwierige
monate stünden bevor aber der winter
werde enden an den neuen beschränkungen
von bund und ländern hat die opposition
große zweifel heike slansky zum zweiten
mal in diesem herbst rechtfertigt sie
die korona beschränkungen keine aussicht
auf lockerungen die kanzlerin ab
erneut an die bürger wir haben ganz ohne
zweifel noch einmal schwierige monate
vor uns aber so wie wir menschen schon
so viele große probleme in der
geschichte der menschheit gewählten
bewältigt haben
so kann auch jetzt in der pandemie jeder
und jede aktiv dazu beitragen dass wir
diese zeit gut durchstehen mehr als
sieben stunden hatte sie gestern bis
spät in den abend mit den länderchefs
gerungen verlängerung des teil shutdowns
plus einige verschärfungen
fundamentalkritik von der afd
es geht den staat schlichtweg nichts an
wer in seinen privaten wohnräumen wann
wen trifft und mit wem und in welchem
rahmen jemand weihnachten mit der
familie angehörigen oder freunden feiert
die versprochene langfrist strategie
vermissen auch die anderen
oppositionsparteien und fühlen sich als
parlamentarier übergangen
das alles ist wieder viel zu sehr auf
sicht fahren
das ist viel zu wenig planbarkeit und
vorausschau bei schweren
grundrechtseingriff muss der bundestag
entscheiden egal wie sehr sie das nervt
die sozialen und wirtschaftlichen kosten
der pandemie die bekämpfung explodieren
jedenfalls ist das keine langfristig
durch haltbare strategie haushaltsrecht
ist parlaments recht deshalb kritik aus
den eigenen reihen die länder müssten
sich an den kosten beteiligen
ich finde das nicht in ordnung wie die
lastenteilung im bereich finanzen
zwischen bund und länder ist inländer
kriegen über die hälfte der
steuereinnahmen mit den kommunen ich
erwarte von den ländern dass ich jetzt
auch mal endlich finanziell in diese
sache einbringen zufrieden dagegen der
koalitionspartner die ergriffenen
maßnahmen seien angemessen
ich möchte alle die davor warnen die
glauben es gibt die eine entscheidung
die alles besser macht merkel schwört
auf einen harten winter ein und setzt
weiterhin auf solidarität
so und jetzt kommen gerade die meldungen
aus berlin dass es dort keine lockerung
der kontakt regeln über weihnachten
geben soll und am theo koll wirklich
klar für ganz deutschland ist die lage
also bereits einen tag nach dem
beschluss gestern nicht mehr oder doch
eigentlich schon das wurde nur gestern
in der berichterstattung über die
weihnachts lockerung glaube ich von
vielen übersehen die sogenannte hot spot
strategie besagt nämlich genau da es
dort wo mehr als 200 neue infizierte
sind können die länder zusätzliche
maßnahmen entscheiden und in berlin hier
haben wir die situation dass in einigen
bezirken genau diese situation besteht
insofern ist es folgerichtig dass berlin
jetzt genau das entschieden hat man wird
also keine weihnachts lockerungen sprich
also auf zehn personen erweitern sondern
es bleibt bei den fünf personen
weihnachten in berlin heißt feiern mit
maximal fünf personen
jetzt war im vorfeld angekündigt dass es
ein langfristiges konzept geben soll er
also auch deutlich über weihnachten
hinaus für den ganzen winter wo ist denn
das geblieben also wenn man es flapsig
formulieren will irgendwo hier im
november nebel der viren krisenpolitik
berichterstattung ich glaube ein problem
für die politik in dieser
krisenbewältigung ist der zeitversatz
den coup mit sich bringt das heißt man
weiß immer erst sehr viel später welche
folgen die entscheidung hatten
und das führt dazu dass man eher auf
sicht vierten vielleicht noch mehr als
sonst die forderung nach einer
langfristigen strategie werden aber
immer lauter wir sehen ja in anderen
ländern dass das offensichtlich
erfolgreich ist und die die maßgabe aus
dem kanzleramt ist ja auch dass man
weiter planen möchte der
kanzleramtsminister hat heute schon mal
die zeit gabe bis märz in den blick
genommen im kalten berlin theo koll
herzlichen dank für die
hintergründe heute abend ja es gibt
jetzt viele fragen und auch viele sorgen
manche haben sich verstärkt manche sind
neu dazugekommen
wir gucken erst mal auf die reaktionen
aus wirtschaft und kultur auf die neuen
beschränkungen mit bernd mosebach nicole
malessa hatte auf ein lukratives
weihnachtsgeschäft gehofft ihr
schweriner traditionshotel ist
normalerweise in der adventszeit begehrt
bei gästen aus skandinavien
jetzt kommen ein paar geschäftsreisende
der rest ihrer 24 betten bleibt weiter
leer naiv gewesen wenn man jetzt ist
anders erwartet hätte mit den zahlen
nichts desto trotz versuchen wahrheit
das beste daraus zu machen hoffen halt
jetzt die fördergelder dass sie halt
jetzt fließen fitnessclub leiter frank
fleischer bereitet das formular vor für
die november hilfe des bundes seit
gestern kann der antrag gestellt werden
auch im dezember soll es diese
unterstützung geben sein stuttgarter
fitnessstudio hat im sommer erst
eröffnet vor dreieinhalb wochen
beschlossen und das bleibt auch erstmal
so weiter laufen hohe kosten wie miete
versicherungen usw
da hatte ihn römer hilfen bisher noch
nicht angekommen sind noch nicht
beantragt werden konnten
deswegen wir hoffen ja dass er schnell
was kommt für den einzelhandel gelten
künftig begrenzungen für die zahl der
kunden die gleichzeitig rein dürfen kein
problem für reil kieninger und ihren
blumenladen auch bisher hat sie nur drei
kunden auf einmal rein gelassen ihre
kundschaft soll sich schließlich sicher
fühlen und gerade also wenig zum metzger
de oder zum bäcker geht es sind ja
meistens außer beschäftigt ihn zurück
ins große da stellt man sich schon
darauf ein dass man bisher im
mecklenburgischen staatstheater wird
gerade das weihnachtsstück geprobt auch
wenn heute erst einmal alle aufführungen
und bis weihnachten abgesagt werden
mussten und deswegen wird die bühne leer
stehen und das sorgt schon für sehr sehr
viel
unglück am theater also die die stimmung
heute morgen in der leitungs sitzung war
nicht nicht sehr gut
die theaterleute hoffen dass sie ihre
weihnachtsstück dann vielleicht im
januar auf führen können und ein
weiteres streitthema sind seit wochen
die schulen
da hat es gestern keine bundesweit
verpflichtenden regeln aber neue
empfehlungen gegeben
die weihnachtsferien werden vorgezogen
und beginnen in den meisten ländern
zumindest am 19
dezember bei einer inzidenz von mehr als
50 soll ab klasse 7 masken pflicht
bestehen wird ein kind positiv getestet
soll die ganze klasse für fünf tage in
quarantäne und in hotspots kann es ab
klasse 8 wechsel unterricht geben über
die situation in hannover berichtet noll
in bio in der achten klasse am wilhelm
raabe gymnasium in hannover
sie sind alle wieder da lernen gemeinsam
vor zwei wochen gab es einen positiven
corona fall eines schülers die klasse
wurde in den wechsel unterricht
geschickt das abwechselnde lernen zu
hause und in der schule ein modell was
bei vielen schülern gut an kamen bald
könnte nach den beschlüssen dieses
szenario wiederkommen ich persönlich
fände es ihr besser weil man dann eben
auch die halben gruppen hätte ich finde
das gut dass man das dann zu machen
könnte dass man dann ein bisschen
homeschooling macht und dann halt in der
klasse dann die abstände besser
einhalten kann und so doch schuldirektor
martin thunig sieht auch nachteile beim
unterricht im wechsel modell aus
pädagogischer sicht ist eine katastrophe
weil sie natürlich nicht an die schüler
denken die sich nicht selbst
organisieren können die nicht selbst
lernen können die vor allen dingen zu
hause kein eigenes arbeitszimmer haben
kein oder noch nicht mal einen ruhigen
platz wo sie sich zurückziehen können
diese schüler und das gehört zum zur
ernsthaftigkeit die verliert man beim
wechsel unterricht wechsel unterricht
bei hohen infektionszahlen masken
pflicht ab der siebten klasse die
beschlüsse der kanzlerin und der länder
zum schulunterricht sind nur
empfehlungen letztlich entscheiden die
bundesländer selbst wir hätten uns
gewünscht dass dabei rausgekommen wird
das ist klar
also rote oder einfache deutliche
signale gegeben hätte die regeln ab wann
man wie entscheidet die sollten in bunde
in allen bundesländern gleich sei
niedersachsen verschärft nachdem bund
länder beschlossen die regeln für
schulen in corona hot spots ab dezember
gilt schon ab der siebten klasse geht es
bei der überschreitung des grenzwertes
von 200 neuinfektionen pro woche ins
wechselmodell neue krone regeln gibt es
auch bei der bahn dort können zum
beispiel sitzplätze neben einzel
reservierungen nicht mehr besetzt werden
in der zdf- heute erfahren sie
detailliert welche neuen maßnahmen und
regeln es gibt und welche ausnahmen für
weihnachten geplant sind
es geht darum die zahl der
neuinfektionen zu drücken denn bislang
bleiben sie hoch das robert koch
institut meldet 22 1268 neue fälle
innerhalb von 24 stunden das sind 341
weniger als vergangenen donnerstag die
zahl der todesfälle in verbindung mit
chor witt 19 ist seit gestern gestiegen
um 389 der problematischste corona
hotspot in deutschland das ist der
thüringische landkreis hildburghausen
mit mehr als 600 neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohnern in einer woche
deshalb gilt dort eine strenge ausgangs
beschränkung gegen die gestern abend
etwa 400 menschen in der innenstadt
lautstark protestiert haben viele ohne
abstand und ohne masken
die polizei hat die versammlung
schließlich mit hilfe von pfefferspray
aufgelöst zu dem protest war im internet
aufgerufen wurden
unsere reporterin melanie haack ist in
hildburghausen und beantwortet ihre
fragen zur lage dort in einem live
stream um 20 uhr das ganze auf unseren
social media kanälen und in der zdf-
heute- app so viel in dieser sendung zum
thema corona noch nie waren so viele
illegale drogen in deutschland im
verkehr wie aktuell das sagt die
drogenbeauftragte der bundesregierung in
ihrem jahresbericht große probleme
bereiteten
der steigende cannabiskonsum und auch
kokain
in der mitte der gesellschaft angekommen
den größten gesundheitlichen schaden
richteten tabak und alkohol an besonders
raucher hätten ein doppelt so hohes
risiko für eine schwere ko witt 19
erkrankung so jetzt sollten wir auf ein
land schauen in dem die lage für
millionen menschen verzweifelt ist nach
17 jahren bürgerkrieg der sudan anfang
oktober schloss die übergangsregierung
dort frieden mit einigen rebellengruppen
die hatten sich 2003 in dafür später
auch in anderen provinzen gegen die
arabische mehrheit aufgelehnt geschätzt
300.000 menschen kamen ums leben mehr
als sieben millionen sind immer noch auf
internationale hilfe angewiesen die aber
reicht nicht aus berichtet uli gack aus
davor unter schutz von un
friedenstruppen lebensmittelverteilung
in davor stabiler camp eines von
dutzenden flüchtlingslagern in der
region
die zahl der bedürftigen steigt dem
welternährungsprogramm der un fehlen die
mittel rationen sind hier gekürzt
wichtige kindernahrung gibt es derzeit
nicht wir wollen dass die un mehr
verteidigt es reicht nur noch für eine
mahlzeit am tag das ist zu wenig rasch
aufeinanderfolgende krisen
mangelernährte kinder
man müsse beim helfen prioritäten setzen
sagt man hier alles andere sei illusion
wenn sie leute vor sich haben die idee
die wirklich auf unsere
nahrungsmittelhilfe angewiesen sind dann
ist es sehr schwer zu sagen
sie bekommen es noch diesen monat und
sie bekommen es nicht mehr
es sind sehr schwere fragen für weitere
nahrungshilfe im sudan sind in den
kommenden monaten über 150 millionen
dollar zusätzlich nötig so die ul
zu unübersichtlich ist die lage im davor
zu groß ist das gebiet niemand weiß
genau wie viele kugeln leiden
hilfsorganisationen kommen an ihre
grenzen man könne nicht mehr allen
helfen heißt es hier
seit 2004 läuft der hilfseinsatz in
darauf fuhr ein ende der mission ist
nicht in sicht
hunderte angeklagte hunderte urteile
heute in der türkei ein gros prozess
rund um den putschversuch vor mehr als
vier jahren fast 400 militärs und
zivilisten wurden in ankara verurteilt
mehr als 300 von ihnen zu lebenslangen
haftstrafen
laut gericht waren sie beteiligt an dem
gescheiterten putsch im juli 2016 bei
denen es etwa 250 tote gab
seitdem ist die türkische regierung
immer wieder hart gegen die opposition
vorgegangen
zehntausende menschen wurden
festgenommen in den usa hat präsident
donald trump seinen ehemaligen
sicherheitsberater michael flynn
begnadigt und damit auch für empörung
gesorgt flynn muss damit jetzt auf jeden
fall nicht mehr in haft
ihm wird vorgeworfen bei den
ermittlungen über eine mögliche
einflussnahme von russland auf die
präsidentenwahl 2016 gelogen zu haben
trump hatte das ganze immer als
hexenjagd bezeichnet für die demokraten
ist die begnadigung machtmissbrauch und
wir bleiben noch im moment in den usa
das land feiert heute des tanks gewinnen
aber das wichtige große familienfest
wird überschattet von der korona krise
millionen amerikaner reisen quer durchs
land trotz eindringlicher warnungen der
behörden
die usa haben weltweit mit abstand am
meisten fälle fast 2300 kurve tote gab
es gestern in nur 24 stunden ein
erntedankfest mitten in der pandemie das
ist kein fußballer das ist ein künstler
ein tänzer hat franz beckenbauer gesagt
über diego maradona
viel abschied heute von den großen
fußball genau die verehrung riesig groß
die anteilnahme auch adiós gott des
fußballs weit über die landesgrenze
hinaus wird nach dem tod von
argentiniens ikone diego armando
maradona überaus emotional abschied
genommen
tiefe trauer und betroffenheit hat die
fußballwelt erfasst eine schier endlose
schlange windet sich die straße entlang
zum präsidentenpalast in buenos aires
die argentinier verabschieden sich von
ihrem fußballgott diego maradona seit
sechs uhr morgens zieht sich ein strom
von menschen vorbei am sagt es mit
sechzig jahren verstorbenen idols noch
heute soll diego maradona mit einem
staatsbegräbnis in der nähe von buenos
aires beigesetzt werden
auch in neapel wo die menschen ihn
verehren wie einen heiligen kann man
trotz ausgangssperre bereits in der
nacht zusammen
maradona ihr messias hatte dem ssc
neapel die größten erfolge beschert zwei
meistertitel und den uefa pokal
er war einer von ihnen und soll es für
immer bleiben die app ist bürgermeister
bilder stadio san paolo in maradona
stadion umbenennen und auch der
europäische profifußball nahm abschied
bei allen champions league partien gab
es eine schweigeminute
ja und am ende des vierten spieltages
der königsklasse gab es zwei klare
heimsiege für deutsche vereine borussia
mönchengladbach rückt nach dem 14 0
gegen schachtjor donetsk dem
achtelfinale immer näher
die bayern sind dagegen schon in der ko
runde drei zu eins gegen salzburg ein
starker torwart und große effizienz
zeichnen die bayern vor allem aus in
diesem spiel robert lewandowski nutzte
eine der wenigen münchner möglichkeiten
kurz vor der pause zum 1 0
salz kurz rüber fällt dann einen command
schuss unhaltbar ab und lisa d trifft
per kopf
trotzdem fehlt aktuell die
selbstverständlichkeit im bayern spiel
wir können uns das leben etwas einfacher
machen wenn man uns aktuell ein bisschen
zu kompliziert dazu passen auch die gelb
rote karte für den spanier marc rocker
und der viel zu einfache gegentreffer
durch berisha platz eins in der gruppe
und das achtelfinale sind trotzdem
gesichert
weitspringer markus rehm ist für
deutschlands para sportler des
jahrzehnts gewählt worden
der dreimalige paralympics-gewinner und
mehrfacher weltmeister setzte sich bei
der auszeichnung des deutschen
behindertensportverbandes vor dem
früheren alpinen skifahrer und
erfolgreichsten deutschen beifahrer
winterspielen gerd schönfelder sowie
kugelstoß weltrekordler nico kp durch
vielen dank christian schauen wir noch
aufs wetter morgen wieder ein nebliger
tag wie heute auch schon gut zum
fernsehen
denn terry hat gleich alle details ich
empfehle ihnen das heute journal mit der
kollegin marietta slomka viertel vor 10
vom gesamten heute 19 team danke fürs
zuschauern und in allen einen sehr
angenehmen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter den typischen
nebelgebieten gab es heute von der sonne
keine spur von meinen bis zur donau
runter aber auch hier mittelrhein
da war es ziemlich dicht und grau in
grau aber viel sonnenschein doch dann im
südwesten vor allem aber über den bergen
da schien die sonne
dazu hatten wir noch ein wolkenband im
norden dass seine kaltfront und daraus
geregnet und in der kommenden nacht
regnet es hier weiter von der oder über
die elbe bis zur ems im süden bildet
sich dagegen dichter nebel und es wird
glatt denn die temperaturen sinken auf
null bis minus 5 grad im südosten bei 3
bis 6 grad bleibt es im norden etwas
milder unter den kompakten wolken morgen
im tagesverlauf gibt es dann im norden
noch etwas regen das lästern allmählich
nach nach süden gibt es nebel in den
typischen nebelgebiete muss man sagen
wieder richtung donau ansonsten
sonnenschein über den bergen nach osten
hin sind die wolken etwas kompakter bei
temperaturen von maximal 0 grad im nebel
im südosten an der donau und 11 grad im
südwesten am oberrhein und die kommenden
tage am samstag ist etwas weniger nebel
dabei im westen sogar sonnige abschnitte
bei 2 bis 10 grad am sonntag wird es
kühler oder etwas schnee auch dabei ein
schöner abend